hello guys Gregory
hello I'm jabbing away Jabby my broseph
I took my family a little family trip in
Ventura visit us I'll give you the exact
address if you message me personally
just joking anyway the rogue one trailer
just dropped this is gonna be the only
video I film all weekend I'm gonna take
a break from the internet for a few days
but I know there's a lot of anticipation
around this he literally just knocked on
my bedroom door saying he arrived and I
said ro1 trailer drop come sit down
that's what we're doing right now I just
cut out a litter our long drive
literally exactly how this is going this
is life right now life I guess mom's
watching that really loud see no one
woman watching us you should shut that
off you ready jebin
Reserve is coming undone Imperium Flags
bring across the galaxy
can you be trusted without your shackles
let's just get this over with shall we
we've a mission for you
on a pretty people we need to know how
to destroy yes
really doing this I want to help
good
I've been recording for the rebellion
for the Empire
I fear nothing more is as the fourth
will be so glad is here the captain says
you are a friend I will not
there isn't much time
every day they grow stronger
haha like a war movie
there's 97.6% chance of failure
in me as well
god damn
are you with me
oh yes okay great way to leave that as a
last-second tease okay what's going on
oh my god do you know the story I know I
don't know the story at all this story
takes place in between Episode three and
four because Episode four starts off
where the rebels have acquired the
plants that Death Star so right no I
mean I know I know the basic of it but I
don't know like the details within I
just everything's looking largely a
mystery to me I didn't even know Darth
Vader was gonna make an appearance in
this movie oh yeah that's been highly
talked about a James Earl Jones is gonna
come back and do the voice too
that's cool before watching this trailer
I was I was watching the comic-con panel
for a little bit and Felicity Jones was
talking about how her character is gonna
be different from the likes of someone
like ray or Luke because she's someone
who actually really knows herself she's
someone who has a really dark past and
is trying to do right this time and I'm
a big fan of characters who are looking
for redemption as God knows I'm looking
for left and right every day of my life
was it wasn't fin looking for redemption
yes
yes he was so and I liked fin so okay so
like why she's different she's different
from the female characters as what she's
implying yeah I guess well she also
mentioned Luke he's kind of girly okay
three do you know what I enjoyed in that
aesthetically is the the shots were like
when it was going into hyperspeed and it
was kind of blurred out I knew it was
for cast up focus on like I like they
were playing with how you shoot a Star
Wars movie
exactly I'm liking that a lot or even
when she's walking up on the catwalk and
she's looking at this ship what I
thought I fighter yes that's what it's
called I know these things you it's just
the way it's rack focusing it's like
I've never seen a Star Wars where we do
that well that's why I was really happy
with the choice of Gareth Edwards as
director because I know he did Godzilla
and that was a totally different take
than what we were expecting out of like
what we know of gods a load of beat now
I did hear all the rumors like these are
highly talked about rumors that are
still the rumors but they supposedly
there was a test screening for Disney
Disney thought it was way too dark which
was yeah one that I thought was way too
dark and like they said they have they
want to do reshoots to make it lighter
and more on tone with the other Star
Wars movies my first thought was I
understand that because of the franchise
but when it comes to this just being a
spin-off movie I'd like it if they could
just take whatever approach they want to
take with it and gareth edwards knows
how to provide that like haunting more
slower-paced menacing touch as opposed
to what like JJ abrams would have
brought us I wonder if they'll release
like a special edition version that is
more dark in tone and whatnot like a
director like a hardcore Gareth Edwards
he's probably we're probably never gonna
see Darth Vader in this like ten minutes
of Darth Vader that's his thing what
would the Godzilla joke I like a force
Whitaker is doing though that the
character he's creating is is different
than other things like the last time
I've seen him do something really
different was Last King of Scotland it
feels like something different from who
he usually is I heard his characters
derive from Star Wars the Clone Wars
I don't know who exactly his character
is Donnie Yen I here is a blind guy and
I you know what I realized
I think the blind community is
eventually going to take a stand we've
got two characters in daredevil who are
blind you got this movie coming out
called don't breathe about a blind guy
and then you got this movie coming out
with a blind warrior but the prom
they don't cast any real blind actors to
play these characters I'm sure the blunt
communities like mean he's very upset
when they watch these little suckers I
have you know as someone who's actually
bug Donnie Yen as an addition in this if
you're gonna bring in an Asian actor
into the Star Wars world feel like
Donnie Yen is the great international
choice well he just has a certain
serious tone to him that you always get
with every Donnie Yen film you see like
I had over I can't recall one Donnie in
film I've seen that was comedic and it
and I think he's I trust him so much
like I feel like he's such a nice sweet
guy where I some when he's like getting
pissed but most of the time he seems
like just a really nice sweet guy who
cares to do the good thing all the time
and knowing that like kind of peaceful
Zen warrior I feel like that would be a
nice touch remember in the Matrix
Reloaded they had the Seraph carrier who
could have been like a cool capitalized
pawn Asian character and I got sidelined
yeah you got a sideline and I feel like
with this I hope that doesn't happen
because fans are really excited that
Donnie yen's a part of this and it man
is like a huge hit even in the States
that's a lot of characters I'm I would
not be surprised if Donnie Yen got
sidelined well it sounds like it's going
to be felicity jones and diego luna who
will be the two main characters the rest
of the cast will kind of be like the
characters you cut to have the cool
things they do or have their special
moves but that still doesn't mean that
they won't shine it all right how much
more than the trailer showed us do you
think Donnie Yen will actually be
fighting 15 minutes that is the one
fight scene they gave him and so they
only
I think his fight scene will be maybe a
minute or two long yeah least you see
when gears that were set out to make
this he said that he wanted to make a
war movie like it's called Star Wars and
he wanted to bring a dark world together
so no [ __ ] well yeah there's like no
Jedi's there's no God coming to save
them it's just the humans who have to
battle evil this is a Star Wars Episode
eight I would get like the tone issue
but like I said this is a prequel slash
spin-off so why not go all out with the
darkness on this story no I remember in
your other reaction you said it felt a
lot like Hunger Games do you still feel
that one now definitely not definitely
not I was like how it's not always shot
because some [ __ ] like that one shot
where she's talking to that robot who's
like I won't hurt you
that had that like handheld touch to it
were looked real kind of like what Neill
Blomkamp would do but then he's a guy
deal like Chad you know happy yes I
didn't see chappie I saw the district
chappie like Star Wars sorry okay so
district 9 yeah so you had that little
touch there but I like how the chiller
is not filled with constant trying to
look realistic but it feels like it will
take its time more than the other Star
Wars movies we've seen as of late which
is just one Star Wars movie scene is
oblique so that robots like the comedic
relief like c-3po
that robot is gonna be the star of this
whole movie my brother I'm kind of
speechless I I mean it looks so good it
looks so much better than the teaser let
on and as yeah it looks better to me
that Episode seven did and what I will
say too is like there's a there's
something mysterious about it like even
though we know that the rebel plan will
succeed in the end we don't know who's
gonna live or die by the end I still
feel that there's some source um stuff
here that is gonna really enhance the
Star Wars story and the whole mythology
the legacy overall I feel like there's
gonna be things in there like I didn't
know that or that's a cool thing to
throw in there cuz I like how the Star
Wars films are now starting to take even
more from their canon of like their
comic books and their shows and it's
it's cool that they're working with it
all now I really appreciate how they
were able to bring back the look of the
way characters the costume design the
hair design everything like that from
the 70s films
yeah the late 70s and early 80's it
plucked these people out of that
universe and and shot it modern
yes any kind of sense not totally I know
JJ Abrams what force awakens wanted to
honor the original look but it did take
place later than Return of the Jedi
right so he had to still update some
looks while honoring the original this
one is like just honoring the original
look which is cool because now it's like
we get to experience Star Wars again
it's honoring the original look but it's
shot differently yeah and the CGI does
look really good
it's like Steven Spielberg went back and
shot a war movie in the Star Wars
universe
this is gonna be violent no there's two
Asian characters in here well it can't
be that violent it needs to be super
violent here this will be the first
r-rated Star Wars movie no it's not
that's why it's called rogue one I like
the part when they when she shot the
bazooka that was great
that was really cool that looks [ __ ]
awesome I hope Felicity Jones lives in
the end and they somehow bring her back
as like a really old character like
Peggy Carter in the Captain America
movie you know she's like a really old
lady by the time they bring her back
she's not able to kick ass she's just
sick taking the Episode 7 trailer and
the rogue one trailer now we've had some
time away from episode 7 do you feel
like the road 1 trailer is more exciting
to watch than the Episode 7 trailer no
no only because
and force awakens was like we gained
stars again after a very long time and
it feels like they're gonna do it right
what excites me more about this trailer
is I feel like there will be something
different to offer more different to
offer like I think the force awakens
offered a lot of unique things but for
some reason like half the people who saw
I thought it was exactly new hope there
was exactly it's not exactly new hope
pretty much inspired by an you oh it's
not exactly any volts be there's be
plenty of different things that happen
it's a call to different move it's
pretty much doing okay so I feel like
with this story this feels much grounded
more in a human world because this is
from humans point of views like with the
force awakens it felt like we were
dealing more with the fantasy of the
force and stuff although Donnie Yen
supposed to be that character it's just
about the Sam like I'm pretty sure the
force is gonna play a role in all of
this just not quite as heavy I always
feel like the force was the worst part
of the Star Wars movies I want you all
to know that the worst part okay is the
one thing that doesn't work for me all
right that's a good joke it's a joke
I love Hayden Christensen as Anakin
Skywalker bring him back Jar Jar Binks
he was pretty fun all right Star Wars
fans subscribe please
I was joking about that last stuff I was
talking about too for you guys who don't
understand what sarcasm is or jokes or
jokes or just don't find me funny or
humor chebika a yes um is an adopted
family member of mine that's why it has
a different name his parents were killed
there were two lights in there yellow
and red still to this day he doesn't
know who did he was shown represent what
you know shown referencing I want to
give a shout out to my sister it was her
birthday yesterday
happy birthday mcgunn that's the correct
way to pronounce her name she's an
artist she has curly hair and she gets
irritated easily and I love you
well as do the rest of our bloodline